if mr. robot and Phil of the future had
a lovechild it would be me
these are BuzzFeed's most and out
comments of 2017 let's dive in and I
hope I'm not too fragile the white guy
in the flannel needs to contain his
forehead listen people have big
foreheads I'll say I'm in like the five
head club you can blow that up in blows
so my name is Michelle no I'm a food
writer here and obviously on my byline
my name shows up right below on my post
title and this is one of the comments I
got all I see is Michelle no like she's
that person in the group of friends that
makes crazy decisions and everyone gotta
hold her back why does the girl with the
dreads look like Nick Cannon this blonde
guy looks like a pervert it has
disgusting armpit stains cut him off
BuzzFeed your I hope you die and that
mustache rots off you everyone loves
that movie and you try to ruin it I hope
you die right there in Vietnam it locks
gay being gay school
it looks good thumbs up to the guy who
made the ice cream tasted it with a fork
and didn't put it back in there but
instead turn the fourth the other way
and used it
yay no saliva and ice cream don't double
dip guys that's not oh you guys
definitely boosted my confidence so I
got the black girl with the dredge is so
gorgeous stop it guys stop it
I love all your recipes and I'd like to
know more thank you for sharing so much
knowledge
it's so nice to see these because I get
so many negative comments I mean that
just comes with the territory so for
like a nice comment like this gives me a
boost I just released a video where I
become friends with a hundred strangers
and someone sent me hey you dude sorry
this is so random I just watched your
video about making a hundred friends in
a day it's probably the one fear which
is holding me back from moving abroad to
work this is probably sounding cheesy
but honestly it's giving me a little
more confidence to think that it's not
that hard and I might be able to do it
so yeah thanks peace sign that was a
really nice message I didn't think the
video was like that powerful but it's
like cool to see how much a video can do
when you're working for such a big
platform and how it can really affect
people and all matrix her butthole that
was an interesting one listen I love
comments you guys really keep me up at
night
seriously I really stay up at night
reading comments cuz you guys are really
funny
I go through them to see people being
like this is so helpful thank you so
much but I also go through them for
ideas like for example I just saw an
eggplant moussaka idea I'm here from
someone that I'm like I should probably
make that video sometimes it's a little
tough reading comments because like
there will be a lot a lot of positive
comments and it's like I love this kid
and then the comment
right after his I hate this kid so it's
like an emotional rollercoaster reading
comments I love comments when you put me
down I love comments when you call me
out I love comments when you say I look
stupid I'll tell you why I get paid
comment resolution for 2018 has come up
with another comment other than BuzzFeed
is running out of ideas because guess
what you're running out of ideas because
content in that College